meghan markle can officially add
children's book author to her
impressive resume the 39 year old
duchess of sussex has written her first
children's book titled the bench
megan's literary debut is illustrated by
best-selling artist
christian robinson and the audiobook
will be narrated by megan herself so i
can't wait
so what's the book about it tells the
story of the quote
special bond between father and son as
seen through a mother's eyes
and is inspired by her husband prince
harry's relationship with their nearly
two-year-old son
archie the book will be released on june
8th
ahead of father's day on june 20th i
would say i'm just really thrilled
in a statement megan explains quote the
bench started as a poem i wrote for my
husband
on father's day the month after archie
was born
that poem became this story the former
suit star adds that she worked closely
with the artist to depict this special
bond through an
inclusive lens and her hope is that the
book
resonates with every family no matter
the makeup
look the duck is so hot he's getting a
drink of water
no the rabbit is so hot he's cooling off
his ears
that's the sun and what's that fish
let's turn the page let's see what else
happens the announcement was made just
two days before archie's second birthday
the duchess is currently pregnant with
the couple's second child
a baby girl who is due this summer i'm
sure they've probably got a very good
idea
of what they're going to call their
little girl and i think many people are
expecting that diana is going to be
one of her names bt spoke with royal
expert katie nichol last month
who shed some light on how the couple is
planning to spend the months
after becoming a family of four megan is
going to take some maternity leave she
didn't have much maternity leave last
time around she was really busy
launching a clothing collection for
smart work she was
putting the finishing touches to her
vogue issue so i think she worked
incredibly hard during her first
pregnancy
and didn't take much maternity leave but
i'm told second time round
she's actually going to make a point of
taking some time out
enjoying this time and prince harry is
also going to take his maternity leave
too
you know he's a very much a modern dad
and he's entitled to that time
you